日本語を勉強し出す前に知っておきたい
こと目標が字幕なしでアニメを見ることで
あれば漢字を勉強する必要は全くない
そっか蟹身を見るだけだったら感じ勉強し
なくていいねやだったそもそも授業に行く
必要もない頑張って漢字を勉強しても
スマホに触れた瞬間にそれを全て忘れて
しまうからどっちみち6羽がいいえははい
を意味すはいはいいえを意味すはいがはい
を意味するときもそして良い映画 ea を
意味する時もある最も良い薬が直訳でや
るっていうケースは非常に珍しい
これは仕方がないそれは失礼のそれは丁寧
すぎるそれは友達のいとこと話している
ときにしか使いあなたが照り焼きチキンと
呼んでいるものは照り焼きチキンではない
癖にパースペシャルアーちゃんからメイク
スパイスでカタカナのいいところは
あれカタカナのいいところはなんだ空気は
吸い込むものではなく読むものゾウは鼻が
ながカラオケと発音する先にををつけると
丁寧な言い方になる例えばお忙しいところ
とかお前とかってなぜか勉強しているのは
実は英語だ50の先生から学ぶスラングは
午後に等しい東京にいる僕と一緒に勉強し
ようっていう動画のコメントを読むことは
勉強ではなくな付く頻度が足りないそれ
なら明白っていう言葉が適切かなこうじゃ
なくて
方
これが日本のまだ目標によってアニメを
使っての勉強は全然ありだ例えば
android になるつもりの人たちは
攻殻機動隊を見るとも言えば適当
もう正しい訳は her first 悩ま
ずに住んで良かったね付の発音をできる
ようになってもそれを外来語のなか言うと
必ず英語の f に戻ってしまうグラミン
者になりたいっていう気持ちがいずれ
無くなるだろう鉛筆の持ち方間違って唇を
動かしすぎ関西弁ができる外国人がいくら
でもいる特別感を求めるなら鹿児島弁の方
が日本にはそれあんまり言わないかそれで
も謝った方がいい誰が何と用途
あなたは日本語が上手じゃ
me